the sort of uh Positive Vibes only Trend
online and the kind of don't allow
yourself to think any negative thoughts
and that kind of thing and um I don't
really buy into that side of things
because in order to do that successfully
you have to really deny your own human
brain and you know because if we think
of it as as in your brain is set up to
kind of you know help you survive but
also to help you generate meaning and
understand your environment and what's
going on around you and what demands are
on you and if your brain is doing that
well then a fair degree of the time it's
going to come up with some sort of
negative ideas about what's going on
right because the world isn't you know
Barbie land or whatever um and so if you
then if if you set yourself up with this
idea of I'm not going to have any
negative thoughts I'm going to be so
positive and then you inevitably have a
a negative evaluation of something you
then criticize yourself for being so
negative